I'm going to have to Pivot very quickly
because we've had some breaking news
through and you will understand when you
hear what that news is we've heard from
the UK prime minister on Nadim zahawi
and if you remember he's asked his
ethics advisor to look into whether or
not the Dooms are high we broke the
ministerial code in relation to his tax
Affairs he's put out a statement where
he says it's clear that there has been a
serious breach of the ministerial code
he says as a result I've informed you of
my decision to remove you from your
position in government so that there is
a letter from the prime minister to
Nadim zahawi saying that he has been
removing him from government so he's
effectively in sacked from the
government because it is clear to the
Prime Minister there has been a breach
of the ministerial code